place donc à notre second débat que nous
consacrons ce soir un anniversaire
quelque peu oublié le 15 octobre 1983
une poignée d'enfants d'imigré s lancé
depuis Marseille pour une longue marche
de 1200 km à travers la France ça se
terminera 2 mois plus tard à Paris par
une manifestation de 100000 personnes
rebaptisé La Marche des beurs par les
journaux ce fut en fait la première
irruption dans le paysage médiatique
politique d'une jeunesse issue de
l'immigration confrontée aux
discriminations aux violences policières
aussi 40 plus tard qu'en reste-t-il on
fait le point et surtout on revient là
où tout a commencé c'està-dire au
minguette près de Lyon avec ce reportage
de Samia deschir et Adrien P au départ
ils sont à peine une vingtaine le 15
octobre 1983 des jeunes s'élancent de
Marseille direction Paris à pied ils
entament une longue marche pour
l'égalité et contre le racisme à travers
la France l'idée est né ici dans le
quartier des Minguettes en banlieu
lyonnaise l'époque Jamel Atala n'a que
19 ans il n'est pas politisé mais un
événement va tout changer c'était en
tout début de soirée de là-haut on
entendait un enfant crier au secours au
secours Aï Aï Aï donc naturellement en
entendant ces cris tous les trois nous
descendions ici et on voit un chien
déchicter un gamin et il y avait un
policier donc policier cophile qui était
présent et qui laissait le chien faire
son boulot donc arracher un gamin donc
naturellement on est descendu ti il a
pris le chien il a il a écarté et quand
il a eu le malheur de de mettre un pied
devant il y a eu la détonation son ami
Toui jaijja est blessé par un tir
policier s'en suivent plusieurs semaines
d'affrontement entre les jeunes du
quartier des Minguettes et les forces de
l'ordre cet événement ça a été ça a été
déterminant il a fallu que ce drame
arrive pour que l'idée de la de la
marche elle puisse prendre corps enfin
elle puisse se matérialiser au départ
peu médiatisé leur marche va connaître
un écho national après la mort d'un
touriste maghrébain jeté d'un train en
novembre ce meurtre raciste choque le
pays à leur arrivé à Paris en décembre
100000 personnes les rejoignent à
Montparnasse parmi eux le Père Christian
de l'Orme qui a fait toute la marche
avec les jeunes des Minguettes cette
place était était noire de
monde on avait du mal à mesurer parce
qu'on une fois qu'on est arrivé ici on
nous a dit qu'il y avait encore des gens
qui étaient à la place de la
Bastille et pour nous pour moi partic
c'était l'aboutissement d'un rêve
c'était on était soulevé par par la
foule cette aventure rebaptisée Marche
des beurs par Libération c'est lui qui
en a donné l'idée aux jeunes des
Minguettes alors âgé d'une trentaine
d'années le prêtre leur enseigne
l'histoire des luttes non violente de
Martin Luther King et Gandhi et les
convainc de canaliser leur colère dans
une marche pacifique c'était surtout
de d'être efficace dans la protestation
parce que la protestation était légitime
il y il avait des meurtres racistes il y
avait des violences policières donc il
fallait crier il y avait quelque chose à
faire entendre mais mais crier si on
n'est pas entendu si on n pas compris si
on n pas écouté d'abord B c'est c'est
inefficace alors moi je savais que les
moyens d'action en
Finland permettent de de se faire
entendre de toute une opinion publique
suite à la marche le gouvernement
socialiste créent la carte de séjour de
10 ans pour les étrangers mais les
jeunes eux marchaient d'abord contre le
racis
et sur ce point 40 ans plus tard
jamelala est amère cette jeunesse dans
les années 83 elle s'inscrivait dans
dans cette république elle voulait un
traitement égal elle voulait travailler
comme tout le monde et être reconnu
comme un citoyen comme tous les citoyens
bon et ben on constate que 40 ans après
c'est c'est c'est pas le cas donc c'est
c'est c'est le constat il est terrible
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ce
pays est-ce que ce pays il a un problème
avec ses on va dire ses enfants venant
des pays arabes il faut le dire
clairement en 202 2 la France n'a
toujours pas réussi à régler la question
des violences policières désormais la
colère des jeunes ne s'exprime plus
pacifiquement elle explose violemment
comme après la mort du jeune Naël cette
année à
Nanterre que reste-t-il de cette Marche
des beurs comme on disait 40 ans après
mais on va débattre ce soir avec vous
trois Naima Hubert yah bonsoir vous êtes
historienne chercheuse associé à
l'Université de Nice Sofia antipolice
directrice de Pang network c'est un
organisme qui promeut le dialogue
interculturel entre entre les peuples et
à vos côté aclim Mouli bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur du Val de Marne vous avez connu
cette marche des beur puisque vous avez
été à une étape vous allez nous raconter
et puis Olivier Le courour Grand Maison
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes universitaire
politologue et directeur notamment de
l'ouvrage collectif racisme de France
publié aux éditions c'est la découverte
hein c'est ça merci à tous les trois et
puis bien sûr Tam travui qui me qui qui
m'accompagneà dire qui voilà qui reste
là évidemment pour toute la suite de
cette émission alors faut d'abord
rappeler un peu quel était le contexte
qu'est-ce que c'était que la France de
cette époque au début des années 80
quelles sont les difficultés auxquelles
on se heurte quand on est un jeune issu
de l'immigration et qu'on vit dans un
quartier populaire en 1981 en 1982 les
banlieux s'embrasent comme on dit lors
d'été on parle d'été chaud à vénicieux à
vau envelin en région lyonnaise c'était
quoi le quotidien de ces jeunes issus de
l'immigration et contre quoi
protestaient-il alors leur quotidien
c'était des rapports difficiles avec les
forces de l'ordre mais aussi des crimes
racistes et sécuritaires soit lors de
contrôle de police comme l' rappelé
Jamel Atala en parlant de toui jaijja ou
bien dans les quartiers on peut penser à
des affaires qui vont défrayer la
chronique à l'époque dans des quartiers
en périphérie parisienne ou un peu
partout en France oui on rappelle
qu'entre 1981 et 83 euh il y a des
statistiques qui disent qu'il y a une
quarantaine de jeunes des quartiers il
faut le rappeler quand même à nos
téléspectateurs cette époque-là euh qui
sont assassinés par des gens qui parfois
sont envoyés en correctionnel non pas en
cours d'assise et qui parfois ressortent
avec des peines très légère c'est une
ambiance de de de VI écoutez par exemple
le souvenir qu'on a anifa tagelmin qui
était euh à la marche pour pour
l'égalité au départ à Marseille regardez
elle a réussi à visibiliser les
violences policières surtout et les
crime raciste c'était quelque chose que
l'on vivait quasiment ça passait au 20H
une minut et puis on n parlait plus
alors que dans nos familles c'était des
la terreur qui régnait et donc cette
marche elle a permis aussi de de sortir
de cet état de de terreur pour pour agir
tous ensemble vous vous souvenez de cet
état de terreur a climoui bien sûr parce
que il faut savoir quand même que je
viens de ces quartiers populaires de
cette banlieue comme on l'appelle Contin
à diaboliser à stigmatiser alors qu'il y
a de la richesse dans nos quartier et
anifa que je connais bien naimas ce sont
des des camarades de lutte anifa cétait
encore le 17 octobre avec elle à
Marseille et c'est vrai qu'il y avait
vous vous souvenez quand même du climat
on était dans le regroupement familial
c'était aussi ça et donc on découvrait
un peu l'immigration et il y avait une
espèce de déshuminisation c'était en
fait on découvrait que la force de
travail pourvit aussi être une force de
séjour c'estàd il y a des gens qui
allaient s'installer et donc cette
violence il y avait des ratonades je
sais pas si vous en souvenez quand même
et il y avait encore à l'époque il y
avait quand même des des cafés dans
l'est parce que nous on était en région
parisienne mais il fallait voir comment
c'était en province les quartiers sont
très excentrés et il y avait quand même
des cafés où il y avait encore marqué
Inter dit aux chiens et aux Arabes parce
qu'à l'époque on parlait pas de
musulmans comme on le fait maintenant on
a déporté les choses mais il y avait ces
truc arabes c'est vrai qu'il y avait une
violence et Jamel l'a bien dit et c'est
vrai que c'est cette violence qui a fait
que les gens voulaient l'égalité des
droits en fait et cette violence va même
s'exprimer durant la marche on va y
venir on va raconter un peu comment
comment elle s'est lancé mais puisqu'on
en parle on peut on peut rappeler de de
la mort d'Abib grimsy hein défénestré
d'un train par trois candidats à la
Légion ça c'était dans la nuit du 14
novembre 1983 il est il est jeté du
train il est jeté du train et euh de
manière assez dramatique il perdra la
vie à cette occasion et ça va
paradoxalement mettre en lumière cette
initiative pacifique de ces jeunes
maghrébains en majorité qui partent dans
l'indifférence la plus totale le 15
octobre de Marseille avec le soutien
d'association de de la gauche chrétienne
ou d'aide aux travailleurs immigrés mais
qui va être mise en lumière à l'ône de
cette émotion d'opinion publique de ce
crime raciste qui va toucher ce jeune
Algérien et c'est cette ce second
souffle qui va permettre une forme de
fraternité sur le chemin des marcheurs
qui vont être accueilli quelques
semaines après dans l'allèce populaire
que l'on connaît alors 1983 la gauche
elle est au pouvoir depuis 2 ans elle a
soulevé beaucoup d'espoir euh parce
qu'elle avait promis elle l'a fait
d'ailleurs la régularisation de 150000
clandestins l'autorisation du
regroupement familial le droit
d'association pour les étrangers quand
même pour rappeler ces choseslà ça
n'existait pas comme ça spontanément
depuis toujours c'était c'était au début
des années 80 et en même temps en 1983
ben le FN décroche sa première victoire
électorale l'immigration s'impose comme
comme un thème de débat politique est-ce
qu'on peut parler de climat xénophobe à
l'époque pour vous ben les termes qui
ont été employés par celles et ceux qui
viennent de témoigner sont très forts il
parlent de non seulement de climat
xénophobe et de climat racisme mais de
terreur et les crimes qui ont été
rapportés témoign effectivement d'une
extraordinaire violence vous dites
l'immigration oui mais l'immigration
parce que certains et notamment le Front
national à l'époque ont choisit de faire
de l'immigration un thème central de
leur conquête politique et électorale de
mettre ces questions au plus haut de
l'agenda politique alors que ce n'était
pas
forcément le cas ou en tout cas pour le
dire en ces termes c'est pas forcément
les préoccupation qui était majoritaire
parmi les Français comme on dit à
l'époque rappeler que la question
sociale et la question du chômage était
extrêmement importante et rappelez les
mots de François mitteran lors c'est le
début du chômage de Mass et donc c'est
ce sont ces questionsl qui sont au plus
haut de l'agenda politique et évidemment
le Front national va chercher à faire en
sorte que la question de l'immigration
soit au plus haut de l'agenda politique
alors préciser quand même l'expression
issue de l'émigration celles et ceux qui
ont manifesté pour une bonne partie
d'entre eux pour ne pas dire la majorité
d'entre eux ne sont pas issus de
l'émigration ce sont des gens dont les
parents étaient émigrés qui sont
eux-mêmes nés en France c'est la raison
par laquelle je crois qu'il est
préférable de parler d'héritier de
l'immigration coloniale et postcoloniale
parce que l'expression issue de l'
immigration c'est quoi la différence
pour que le téléspectateur compr bien
renvoie systématiquement ceux qui sont
nés en France et ceux qui ont la
majorité la la nationalité française
renvoie systématiquement cela à des
origines étrangères en faisant croire
que ils sont arrivés or eux ne sont pas
arrivés leurs parents sont
éventuellement arrivé mais l'écrasante
majorité d'entre eux sont nés en France
ont fréquenté les écoles de la
République comme on dit et sont pour
l'écrasante majorité d'entre eux des
citoyens français c'est très important
parce que ça veut dire que même s'il y a
des éventuellement des étrangers des
algériens marocains c'est très important
parce que ça permet de comprendre que
cela manifeste non pas pour arracher des
droits spécifiques l'accusation de
communautariste mais pour au contraire
demander l'extension à eux-mêmes d'un
principe de liberté c'est
l'universalisation de la liberté et bien
sûr aussi de l'égalité relativement au
droit juste un dernier point sur la
question de regroupement familial
rappelez que parce qu'il est aujourd'hui
remis en cause qu'il s'agit d'un droit
fondamental sanctionné par des
dispositions européennes et sanctionné
par des dispositions nationales alors on
l'a vu dans le sujet tout à l'heure qui
nous rappelait les conditions de la
création de cette marche pour l'égalité
contre le racisme qui vient au fond
d'une bavure policière puisque ti Jaja
prend une balle tirée dans le ventre par
par un policier lors de l'altercation
qui a été qui a été racontée et en fait
ça va être un curieux attelage qui va se
mettre en place avec donc des un prêtre
le prêtre de la paroisse du
coin un pasteur de la simade et puis des
militants associatifs alors pourquoi la
mayonnaise prend
elle prend elle prend bien avant 83 euh
il ne faut pas euh penser que tout
commence en 83 déjà concernant cet
atelage il existe depuis 81 au moins
depuis les grèves de la fin contre les
expulsions de ceux qu'on appelle les
doubles peines qui sont amenés à être
expulsés suite à des des condamnations
au pénal ces graves de la fin ont été
euh précédemment euh accompagné
également par ceux des mouvements des
travailleurs arabes qui sont leurs aînés
qui dans les années 70 vont se mobiliser
pour les droits l'égalité dans le monde
du travail sur la question des titres de
séjours mais plus tard aussi sur les
conditions de de logement comme les
foyers sonakotra donc c'est
compagnonnage entre une gauche
chrétienne des militants de de gauche et
d'extrême gauche et surtout les
principaux concernés ceux qu'on va
appeler les travailleurs immigrés et
ensuite leurs enfants qui comme l'
rappelé le cour grand maison sont soit
nés en France soit arrivés très jeunes
soit sont issus de l'histoire et la
mémoire Archy c'est ce qui est le cas
d'une partie des marcheurs complexifie
l'analyse et donc l'essentialisation au
mot beur on va y venir à ce choix ce
choix de mot par Libération prédominé
qui a une réalité sociologique à
l'époque de manière anachronique faut
pas rejeter le bébé avec l'au du bain
parlons-en d'ailleurs de ce mot beur
parce qu'en fait le mot beur c'est le
verland d'arabe on le rappelle et au
début des années 80 c'est employé par
les les immigrés arabes de enfin ou par
les enfants de de ces immigrés de
seconde génération et qui s'appelle beur
eux-même c'est revendiqué radio beur par
exemple est créé par par des gens qui
qui revendiquent ce terme c'est
revendiqué mais ça va être très
rapidement galvodé puisqu'on va les
enfermer dans cette catégorie comme des
Français entièrement à part et non pas à
partentière je pense qu'Olivier a mis le
doigt sur une problématique importante
c'est que cette séquence de la marche
pour l'égalité et les suivantes puisque
j'ai vu des images à votre écran de
convergence 84 et d'autres initiatives
insr dans un mouvement de citoyenneté
ces enfants d'immigrés ces héritiers de
l'immigration comme l'a dit Olivier mais
aussi nous donne à penser que la France
se regarde tel qu'en elle-même
multiculturel multiethnique et on voit
aujourd'hui en 2023 qu'on n pas sorti de
cette problématique puisque on continue
à désigner une partie de la communauté
nationale comme des Français de papi on
parle de ces théories d'extrême droit du
Grand remplacement pour ne pas dire que
la France ne se voit pas tel qu'en
elle-même
c'estàdire avec des territoires
ultramarins avec des populations non
blanches et de cultures qui peuvent être
lié à l'histoire coloniale alors ce mot
de beurre en fait il est choisi par
Libération qui parle de marche des
beures pour requalifier de façon plus
plus ramassé cette marche pour l'égalité
et contre le racisme comme on l'a
rappelé mais il va diviser ce mot de
beur certains vont y voir une forme
d'assignation identitaire même un
effacement des revendications politique
et sociale c'était le cas à vos yeux bah
c'est hél ce qui s'est passé alors
libération n'emporte pas spécifiquement
et uniquement la responsabilité mais
rappelez peut-être qu'on y reviendra que
SOS Racisme qui a été créé peu de temps
après et on sait par qui SOS Racisme a
été créé c'est une initiative
présidentielle qui a donné naissance à
cet assass à contribué effectivement à
invisibiliser une partie des
revendications des marcheurs il y en a
une que nous n'avons pas cité et qui
était pourtant présente dans le
programme de franç mitéran en 1981 dans
les S propositions c'est le droit de
vote pour les immigrés euh qui est une
revendication de l'époque et rappeleer
hélas que oui absolument nous je veux
dire nous y sommes toujours ou plus
exactement alors même que en 1983
rappelons cela le Parti socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale Olivier fort va
verser une larme et majoritaire seul à
l'Assemblée bien sûr et doncils avaient
la possibilité de faire voter cette
réforme elle ne l'a jamais été elle est
toujours promise dans les programmes du
candidat à la présidentiel et pas été
appé
ceci que aujourd'hui alors même que les
ressortissants des États-membres de
l'Union européenne disposent du droit de
vote aux élections locales aux élections
européennes sous réserve de
réciprocité cela crée de faites et de
droits une discrimination supplémentaire
à l'endroit des étrangers non
ressortissant des memes de l'UE qui
peuvent constater que effectivement en
matière de droit politique les promesses
jusqu'à présent non hlas jamais été tenu
et les revendications des marcheurs non
plus ce point c'est paradoxal que que
que vous en parliez justement de ce
droit de vote des étrangers parce que
c'est ce que François mitteran qui
reçoit les marcheurs à leur arrivé à
Paris donc on vous l'avez raconté c'est
vrai que à travers les 10000 km ben la
marche va s'étauffer il va y avoir des
gens dans chaque étape qui vont entourer
le mouvement l'alimenter et puis à Paris
on parle de 100000 personnes au point
que une délégation de marcheurs va être
reçu à l'Élysée et François mitteran va
leur promettre des mesures comme la
carte de séjour de 10 ans ou le droit de
vote des étrangers mais en fait c'est
des mesures qui qui les concerne pas
puisque vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
ils sont français
oui mais enfin ça ne les concerne pas
concerne concerne pas forcément
directement mais ça concerne leurs
parents et ça concerne aussi en France
un nombre extrêmement important d'hommes
et de femmes qui sont immigré depuis
très longtemps rappelons que
l'émigration n'est pas un phénomène du
tout nouveau encore les marcheurs étaent
c'est pas c'était pas des revendications
premières marcheurs les marcheurs ont
une revendication universelle celle de
l'égalité de droit à vivre et ne pas
avoir peur de dans l'espace public et de
mourir du fait de leur faciesse ou de
leur patrony leur demande est
difficilement traduisible autrement que
leur dire les lois existent le racisme
est déjà interdit que voulez-vous qu'on
fasse pour vous cette antienne du de la
carte de résidence va être portée par la
génération précédente qui va la réclamer
dans les années 70 et qui va aboutir
grâce à cette séquence porté par leurs
héritiers et c'est cette transformation
d'un combat porté par leurs aînés qui
fait le lien intergénérationnel parce
que peut-être pour pour en parler mieux
que moi mais je dirais simplement qu'il
y a eu une volonté de d'opposer dans le
terme de beurre on rappelle que c un
cvage générationnel entre les les
parents et la prve parce que quand ces
marcheurs vont fraterniser sur les
piquets de grève par exemple chez talbau
poissi avec les travailleurs immigrés il
a une grève assez dure dans décembre 83
faut le rappeler et bien ça va être très
mal reçu notamment dans la presse et
libération ne fait pas exception
puisquelle a couvert avec beaucoup de
bienveillance ce mouvement mais elle n'a
pas pris cette fraternisation
intergénérationnelle on a voulu faire de
ces héritiers de l'immigration des des
euh des possibles citoyens français en
devenir ce que n'était pas leurs parents
aux yeux de l'opinion publique et
notamment des médias qui leur prêter une
vocation à rentrer définitivement dans
leur pays d'origine àlim et Louli est-ce
qu'ils étaient assez politiques les
organisateurs de la manifestation ou
est-ce que d'une certaine façon est-ce
qu'ils sont pas fait avoir par la
politique traditionnelle viendra au cas
de SOS RAC on va on va revenir sur la
effectivement par la poli traditionnelle
le problème c'est que quand le politique
commence à organiser et qu'il prend pas
l'essence ou le sens de l'action
il forcément il détourne de l'objet
initial et d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
ce que disait Naima et ce qu' Olivier
c'est sur la sémantique et sur les
termes faut quand même savoir quand on
disait que c'était pas leur combat la
carte de 10 ans parce que c'est un
combat universel faut le rappeler parce
qu'en valité c'était la marche pour
l'égalité et contre le racisme donc en
fait il marchait pour des des des
revendications universelles et
d'ailleurs les gens l'ont bien compris
parce que quand ils sont arrivés à Paris
et on les a accueill à crétail à bonœil
dans les MJC à l'époque les centres SAU
s'est mobilisé pour faire un accueil
dans des conditions folkloriques he
quand même à brcantes puisque on nétait
pas préparé avoir autant de monde arrivé
il y a des gens de tout bord qui les ont
rejoints des hommes des femmes on a vu
anifa tagilm mais il y avait des des
hommes il y avait des femmes de tous
horizons on a parlé des chrétiens mais
il y avait les protestants il y avait en
fait tout le monde s'était jint il y
avait aussi des gens de la comuné il y
avait vraiment tout le monde il y avait
il y avait une espèce de de découverte
un peu que on pouvait vivre ensemble des
espèce de cohésion cette volonté et sur
les cartes parce qu'il faut pas oublier
quand même qu' vous avez parlé aussi de
radio après mais il faut aussi savoir
que à l'époque avant 93 on n'ait pas le
droit de d'association et donc il y a eu
c'était c'est aussi un acquis qu'ils ont
eu et vous saviez que les nos parents
ils avaient des cartes de 1 an 3 ans 5
ans quand ils avaient 10 ans tu te
souviens c'était le Graal et donc tous
les ans ou tous les 3 ans tous les 5 ans
puisqueà l'épo c'était pas une carte de
séjour c'était une carte de travail et
on savait pas et je ne fais pas de de
similitude avec l'article 3 qu'on nous
propose sur les métiers en tension et
donc en fait les gens les gens se
disaient tous les ans tous les 3 ans
tous les 5 ans on va rentrer chez nous
donc on ne pouvait pas se projeter dans
la société française donc nous nous
étions jeunes insouciant mais avec nous
on entendait nos parents et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'il y a une chanson sur
la carte de résidence d'ailleurs ce qui
a inspiré le groupe avec Rach s'appelit
carte de séjour parce que tout ça était
un vrai Dr drame dans les familles les
gens ne mesurent pas la violence que
vivaient ces familles là et que vivaient
ces enfants c'est important de de le
rappeler oui c'est important et vous
parliez de cette découverte une forme de
de de vivre ensemble en tout cas que que
c'était possible je vous propose
d'écouter le souvenir qu'on a un autre
participant à la marche pour l'égalité
contre le racisme il s'appelle Saïd
bouenouch et il se souvient regardez
beaucoup de jeunes vivaient dans leur
cité ils étaient enferm dans leur cité
et en fait il n'avait pas du tout une
une vue globale de la société française
donc c'est ils étaaient dans une sorte
de ghetto et donc l'idée c'était d'aller
à la
rencontre si on peut dire de la France
profonde
pour avoir ce message de disant ben nous
on est ici et donc on on va avoir notre
place et on veut que les discriminations
cessent que que les problèmes avec la
police
cessent donc cette marche c'est une
réussite dans le nombre c'est une
réussite dans la symbolique c'est la
première fois qu'on parle autant de ces
problèmes de discrimination et en même
temps ce mouvement il va s'étioler d'une
certaine façon dès l'année 1984 et une
association va apparaître et va tenter
de de de
pariner une autre mobilisation une autre
marche qui a lieu en décembre 84 cette
association vend des petits enfinant
donne des petits badg Jaunes vous la
connaissez c'est c'est SOS Racisme qui a
été créé par des proches du pouvoir
politique de l'époque mais qui n'a pris
aucun beur aucun marcheur dans son dans
son état-major dans sa direction ça vous
choque c'est pas que ça me choque ça
c'est l'histoire des rapports de force
en politique on est dans une séquence où
cette jeunesse antiraciste on est en
train de de de de mettre en place une
forme de jeunesse antiraciste puceque à
l'époque l'antiracisme institutionnel
était beaucoup plus âgé on voit là une
force politique pour l'avenir de la
gauche en France notamment pour la
réélection de François mitteran et on y
voit euh une séquence importante pour la
gauche française donc il est naturel du
point de vue politique que le pouvoir de
l'époque veuille capitaliser sur cet
engouement une fois qu'on a dit ça pour
moi c'est un rendez-vous manqué avec
cette jeunesse de l'immigration qui
était laïque citoyenne et qui tendait la
main à cette France qui à l'époque
malheureusement était traversée par ces
bouffés racistes qui accompagnaient
cette crise endémique qui nous ne nous a
pas quitté depuis 40 ans cette jeunesse
n'a pas eu sa place en politique comme
d'autres parce qu'on est dans un système
de baronie de reproduction sociale et ce
rendez-vous manqué hormis quelques
itinéraires individuels très peu
nombreux va se cristalliser autour de
cette ce malentendu et co racisme qui va
porter un combat antiraciste avec des
militant sincère mais qui va faire
l'objet effectivement d'une forme de de
de voilà de téléguidage politique à
l'époque puisque effectivement ils
auront très vite des moyens une force de
frappe de com communication d'engouement
avec des grands concerts des grands des
grands messes dont avait le secret les
années 80 contre un antiracisme
institutionnal qui va écraser ces
initiatives portées à hauteur de ce
qu'on va appeler les beurs puisque très
vite les assises du mouvement beur vont
ne vont rien donner politiquement
Olivier le cours grand maison c'est de
la récupe SOS Racisme et en quoi SOS
Racisme en se limitant à unmage d'une
société multiculturelle va diluer un peu
les revendications des des marcheurs ben
tout d'abord commençons par rappeler
ceci que la marche pour l'égalité contre
le racisme n' une maladie c'est elle
tombe pas du ciel il y a eu des
précédents le MTA et cetera mais c'est
sans doute la première fois à cette
échelle-là que surgit un mouvement
politique de masse et un mouvement
autonomees des premiers concernés et qui
pose beaucoup de problèmes sur le fond
pour les gauches de de gouvernement
parce que justement c'est un mouvement
qui s'est construit à l'écart qui s'est
construit d'une certaine façon en partie
contre eux euh de façon complètement
autonome et qui sur lequel pour le
moment les partis gouvernement et les
associations globalement n'ont pas prise
l'objectif effectivement je crois numéro
1 de SOS Racisme c'est de mettre un
terme à cela et au fond de servir
effectivement comme ça a été dit en
partie la un projet politique
relativement clair qui est d'une part
servir la réélection de françin mitteran
mais aussi au fond promouvoir une sorte
d'antiracisme qui se prétend moral et
qui va à mon sens
contribuer à
invisibiliser l'ampleur des
discriminations systémiques subi par
celles et ceux qui qui ont marché et a
effacé la question sociale et en partie
absolument effacer la question sociale
et en partie minoré ou ehémisé ce qui
est un peu similaire l'ampleur des
violences policières et l'ampleur de ce
que certains aujourd'hui qualifié
qualifie de racisme institutionnel dans
la police je rappelle que sur ce point
il y a des enquêtes très précises et que
même le Défenseur des droits le
Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme et le Conseil des
droits de l'homme de l'ONU a été amené à
prononcer ont été amenés à prononcer euh
des éléments euh très importants
notamment relativement à la question du
racisme et des violences policières en
France alors je vais passer la parole à
th notre éditorialiste parce que vous
êtes intéressé à l'évolution de ce
mouvement antiraciste et et et pour vous
il y a aujourd'hui une forme de de de de
deux antiraciste qui oui il y a deux
formes d'antiracisme qui aujourd'hui qui
coexiste et que l'on oppose he souvent
vous avez l'anti racisme universaliste
qui a la volonté de lutter contre tous
les racismes mais en intégrant tout le
monde et puis vous avez des collectifs
plus récents les plus célèbres étant le
comité Adama qui émane des quartiers
populaires et dénonce une république
raciste alors d'blé il y a une chose que
je vais préciser hein parce que il y a
beaucoup de débat sur ce sujet il y a
pas pour moi dans mon esprit d'un côté
le gentil anti racisme d'ENT temp
universaliste et d'un autre côté un
nouvel antiracisme menaçant et
communautariste bref il y a pas le bon
et le mauvais antiracisme mais bon il y
a bien un mouvement qui a précédé
l'autre déjà vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer il y a eu un antiracisme plus
institutionnel ancien celui qui est né à
la suite de l'affaire drefus avec la LIC
la Ligue internationale contre
l'antisémitisme qui deviendra ensuite la
Licra vous avez aussi là-dedans le le
MRAP le mouvement contre le racisme et
pour l'amitié entre les peuples la Ligue
des droits de l'homme qui ont toujours
travaillé avec les services de l'État
pour lutter contre le racisme et dans
cette mouvance on peut aussi intégrer
vous en avez parlé le plus récent et
fabriqué pour la jeunesse SOS racisme
dont le discours universaliste
généraliste va occuper tout le terrain
médiatique à partir de 1985 avec le
fameux rassemblement de la place de la
Concorde avec ses concerts dont les
années 80 avait le secret où le jeune
arlem désir appelle alors je le cite les
beurs de Bordeaux juif de Toulouse
antillet de Brest français de toute
culture immigré de la première à la 10e
génération à ce saisir de ce combat mais
SOS raciste va vite se retrouver accusé
de faire partie du système mais oui ces
dirigeant va occuper les premiers rôles
politiques à gauche on cite Julien Dray
on site encore arlem desésir FM premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste ministre
sous Hollande SOS Racisme va être accusé
par C détracteur d'avoir fait une opéa
politique sur la marche des beur d'être
une émanation du Parti socialiste un
pote aux rose près de 40 ans plus tard
les rencurs sont toujours là à l'égard
de cette association qui est devenue
pour certains militants antiraciste
l'emblème de l'antiracisme adoubé par le
pouvoir et justement aujourd'hui et bien
cette organisation ne fait plus du tout
recette auprès de la jeunesse retour en
juin 2020 mort de George Floyd début du
mouvement Black lives matter le
rassemblement organisé par SOS Racisme
regroupe à ce moment-là 2500 personnes
quand il y a 20000 personnes qui se
réunissent à l'appel du comité Adama et
les slogan du comité Adama fustige alors
le meurtre des personnes racisées
l'impunité policière car voilà les mots
mot neuf du nouvel antiracisme racisme
d'État privilège blanc racisé ces
nouveaux collectifs considèrent que le
verre est dans le fruit que la
République est intrinsèquement raciste
et que la lutte doit être catégorielle
donc que tout le monde n'est pas
habilité à porter cette cause ces
positions sont-elles compatibles est-ce
qu'il y a deux antiracismes
ilréconciliables comme certains de
gréconciliabl n'est-ce pas bah
fondamentalement ils combattent les
mêmes mot donc ça serait bien qu'ils
arrêtent de se combattre entre eux ils
sont tous les deux les fruits de leur
époque d'un d'un côté un moment où les
institutions se sont plus ouvertes se
sont convertis au combat antiraciste de
l'autre celui d'une époque plus récente
où l'assignation à résidence dans les
quartiers populaires a donné
l'impression que l'universalisme était
un fétiche avec lequel on se donne bonne
conscience alors que la République était
profondément inégalitaire c'est de
combat je dirais qu'ils ont leur raison
d'être parce que le racisme
d'aujourd'hui il a changé de vêtements
ça va être moins direct on va plus
parler de hiérarchie des races mais les
préjugés à l'égard de l'autre ont
toujours la vie dure on va parler de
culture inassimilable on va mettre de
des CV de côté à côté d'un à cause d'un
nom à consonance étrangère on va faire
une plaisanterie tout ça de façon plus
ou moins consciente plus ou moins avouée
et face à ce racisme évolutif je crois
pour une fois au vertuus du en même
temps la France peut regarder son
histoire coloniale tout en regardant
vers l'avenir et l'antiracisme ne
parvient à être un combat universel que
lorsqu'il est réel et bien merci Tam
pour ce point de vue àlim Louli vous
avez été socialiste oui j'ai été
socialiste donc vous avez connu
l'antiracisme de Bonn conscience
certaine façon est-ce que vous avez
connu le le racisme politique bien sûr
c'est ça tout le monde l'a connu c'est
parce qu'on est de gauche qu'on l'est
pas c'est c'est quand même ce serait il
suffit pas de se déclarer pour ne pas
l'être et c'est un travail sur soi au
quotidien et tout à l'heure elle disait
qu'effectivement le Parti socialiste
mais le Parti socialiste c'est mon parti
alors c'est le parti de jores hein après
on peut d'arriver a toujours raté ses
rendez-vous avec les quartiers
populaires
c'est une permanence j'espère qu' ils
retravailleront on l'avait fait en 2012
quand on avait gagné vous vous rappelez
qu'on avait aussi le droit de vote
dessus on avait j'avais fait le travail
de C libération qui le dis si vous
pouvez retrouver pour François Hollande
mais voilà et donc ça on peut le
déplorer mais dans ce que vous dites il
faut on peut s'opposer moi je pense que
la France est quand même un pays de
débat ce qui me pose aujourd'hui
problème c'est pas qu'on a des
divergences et et c'est important parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on fait évoluer y
compris sur cette questionl on avait eu
aussi une divergence en 2003 ou 2004 sur
la les manifestations est-ce qu'on
continuait contre tous le racisme ou
est-ce qu'il y avait des des
spécificités sur l'antisémitisme vous
avez vu qu'il y avait eu il y a eu deux
marches là-dessus il y en a une où il y
avait effectivement SOS Racisme l'AGF la
Licra et d'autres acteurs qui ont fait
une manifestation et une autre où il y
avait effectivement contre contre toutes
les formes de racisme où il y avait les
syndicats les cinq centrales syndicales
il y avait le Brap la LDH la SIMAD il
avait d'autres et donc il y a toujours
eu notre pays a toujours été traversé
par le débat le problème c'est quand il
est dans le dans la haine et quand il
commence à exactement ce que je pense on
peut on peut débattre mais il faut pas
s'annuler c'est ça le problèmeà c'est ça
c'est ce que je dis et aujourd'hui on le
voit le débat c'est pas s'annuler on
peut défendre des causes sans forcément
être contre les autres aujourd'hui on on
est dans un même il comprisement dans un
espèce de débat binaire soit on est pour
soit on est contre alors quand on est
pour on est contre aujourd'hui il y a
des des combats si si on est pour
forcément on n'est pas au milieu on
n'est pas pour la paix et donc tous ceux
qui sont pour faire évoluer les choses
pour être constructif pour être truc
deviennent soit des gens trop modérés
trop mou trop ceci et c'est le problème
qu'on a dans la société mais on est aidé
en cela par rapport à la sémantique et
au journalistes aussi parfois on est
tous respons les politiques les
journalistes et donc aujourd'hui et on
le voit bien tout à l'heure on disait et
c'est vrai que moi ce que jeaais dire
aussi c'est que effectivement nous
devons aujourd'hui pouvoir défendre des
causes et on l'a bien vu et vous vous le
disiez vous-même pour finir c'est que on
a déformé on déforme les combats pour
justement les rendre inaudibles et ça
c'est notre responsabilité de les rendre
audibles le sujet de la convergence des
luttes he c'est ça et sans cynergie des
Lutes il y a pas de lutte bon je
reprends la main 2 minutes parce que le
temps avance et juste pour avant
d'aborder la dernière partie de cette
émission je voudrais qu'on fasse un
point sur bah ce que c'est le racisme
aujourd'hui en France est-ce que on est
on a parlé du contexte tout à l'heure du
début des années 80 et on va regarder un
peu les chiffres en tout cas en terme de
données statistiques d'actes antiraciste
on va faire le point avec audr vuetaz
qui va me rejoindre sur ce plateau parce
qu'en fait tout ça est assez connu
Audrey on peut on a une on a des
chiffres sur l'évolution du racisme en
France oui on a des données très
précises puisque chaque année depuis
1990 la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme un
organe indépendant dresse un état des
lieux du racisme de l'antisémitisme et
de la xénophobie en France état des
lieuux qu'elle remet au gouvernement et
on observe un paradoxe Mathieu car la
société française apparaît de plus en
plus tolérante mais dans le même temps
les actes de racisme et le sentiment de
discrimination augmente en France alors
dans détail je voulais vous montrer un
premier graphique qui va apparaître
c'est l'évolution générale de la
tolérance en France on voit que ça
progresse progressivement mais doucement
plus la courbe est haute en fait et et
plus on est tolérant plus on se
rapproche de 100 plus on est tolérant on
voit que dans les années 90 on est assez
bas 52 voire même une chute à 46 et puis
maintenant on est plutôt autour de 64 66
et puis vous vous demandez peut-être ce
que c'est que cette grosse chute au
niveau des années 2010 et ben ce sont
les conséquences de la crise économique
de 2008 parce que c'est l'un des appren
apprentissage pardon de cette étude en
cas de crise on est moins tolérant autre
information chaque génération est plus
tolérante que celle qui l' précédé et on
voit moins de RAC biologique c'est celui
qui considère qu'une race est supérieure
à l'autre il reste tout de même des
préjugés bien ancrés 60 % des personnes
interrogées pensent que de nombreux
immigrés viennent en France uniquement
pour profiter pardon de la protection
sociale donc il y a un paradoxe parce
que il y a plus de tolérance vous dites
mais plus d'acteurs de racisme oui
deuxième graphique une autre courbe
celle-ci c'est l'évolution des fait
racistes conttabilisé en France d'après
le service central du renseignement
intérieur on voit qu'il y a des pics il
y a des des variation en fonction des
années un pique en 2022 pendant la
campagne présidentielle d'après la
Commission nationale des droits de
l'homme qui a fait l'enquête certains
discours politiques extrémistes ont
exacerbé ces actes une nuance tout de
même à ce graphique on a actuellement
plus de lois plus d'outils pour recenser
ces actes les personnels sont aussi
mieux formés qu'il y a 30 ans mais il y
a aussi des choses qu'on ne voit pas sur
ce graphique et ça s'appelle le chiffre
noir ce sont les actes pour lesquels les
personnes n'iront pas forcément porter
plainte c'est insaisissable on estime
par exemple que seulement 2 % des
victimes d'un jeu raciste pent plainte
ça veut dire que la courbe que je vous
ai montré est en réalité beaucoup plus
importante et bien merci beaucoup Audrey
Olivier Lecour grand maison est-ce que
vous partagez ce paradoxe d'une France à
la fois plus tolérante quand on
interroge les Français mais le racisme
qui est toujours bien bien dans les
préjugés et et de plus en plus d'actes
oui mais parce que un certain nombre de
responsables politique des extrêmes
droites d'Éric Zemour du rassemblement
national et faut-il le rappeler des répu
réublain pte une très lourde
responsabilité dans la
stigmatisation de français alors non
plus ça ça ce sont des personnages
actuel j'allais dire mais si on prend
sur l'échelle des 40 années qui viennent
de se de de se dérouler est-ce que vous
diriez par exemple que la France est
moins raciste qu'aujourd'hui qu'ierier
ou que ce la nature de ce racisme a
changé alors la nature de ce racisme a
changé parce qu'on est effectivement
passé d'un racisme qui reposait sur des
fondements anthropologiques et
biologique à ce qu'on appelle un racisme
culturaliste et différentialiste qui
repose non plus sur des critères
véritablement ethnraciaux mais sur la
mobilisation de deux variables alors qu'
peuvent jouer évidemment ensemble une
variable culturelle et bien sûr une
variable religieuse qui est évidemment
aujourd'hui l'islam et qui est pensé
cette religion et les musulmans vivant
en France qu'il soi français ou étranger
comme les
incarnant à la fois une civilisation une
religion
réputé pas ou très difficilement
assimilable dans les 12 eau de la
République je rappelle que
l'incrimination de
séparatisme qui aggrave celle de
communautarisme et et pour moi
l'expression à la fois juridique et
politique euh de cette conception qui
désigne l'autre en tant qu'il est
musulman ou qu'il est réputé musulman
radical comme faisant peser une sorte de
menace existentielle sur l'unité de la
République sur l'unité de son territoire
et sur ses valeurs et notamment puisque
c'est souvent ce qui est mis en avant
sur l'égalité hommes-femm ce qui est
assez piquant quand on constate
notamment du côté des républicains que
ceux-là qui font grand cas de l'égalité
hommes-femmes sont relativement aux
élections parfois prêt à ne pas
respecter la loi et préfère payer des
amendes que de respecter les quotas
hommes-femm juste un souvenir avec clou
l'Islam la religion on n'en parlait pas
au moment de la marche beur alors on n
parlait pas le l'islam en fait la
religion se se pose à partir du moment
où les gens s'engagent ou s'inscrivent
dans l'histoire de France et donc
forcément à l'époque ils étaient ils
pensaient repartir tous les ans tous les
3 ans je vous l'ai dit à partir du
moment où on est français et qu'on a le
droit de pratiquer donc effectivement ça
apparu mais je crois que l'islam c'est
aussi beaucoup de fantasmes derrière
beaucoup de gens qui parce que
99,99 % des musulmans vivent leur culte
très tranquillement donc il y a aussi et
vivit tranquillement il y a 40 ans voilà
et on a vu apparaître mes parents le
vivaient tranquillement mes parents
respectai mes parents moi j'ai été
éduqué par des gens quand je leur disais
l'instituteur m'a dit il m'a dit je
t'envoie à l'école pour étudier et non
pas pour faire la la leçon à
l'instituteur donc si tu veux apprends
deviens quelqu'un et après tu pourras
porter ta voix mais nos parents étaient
très respectueux et quand on dit
effectivement c'est vrai que l'islam
aujourd'hui c'est parce que on a vu
émerger sur la scène politique et vous
l'avez dit précédemment des gens qui ont
fait de l'immigration qu'on escamootter
la question sociale à la question de
l'immigration c'est ça toute la
supercherie et ça ça nous a amené
effectivement aujourd'hui à faire en
sorte qu'aujourd'hui on le traduit plus
par l'Islam parce que c'est plus vendeur
donc dès que vous dites un mot vous êtes
islamiste c'està-dire que même nous moi
par exemple j'ai été élu par des des
élus des grands électeurs il y a des
gens qui ont quand même trouvé la force
de dire il y a peut-être un vote
communautaire c'est dire que nous eux si
les gens d'origine diverse mais qui sont
français en plus vote pour eux c'est un
vote un très bon vote mais s'il votait
pour quelqu'un qui s'appelle Mohamed
Mamadou et cetera ah bah c'est
communautaire donc il y a un peu
d'escamotage politique et de
l'incohérence dans les discours naïba
Hubert Yahi au fond cette cette marche
pour l'égalité contre le racisme
c'est pour vous si vous dites c'est un
moment fondateur ou c'est un raté
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui c'est un moment fondateur à à
différents niveaux cette marche a
bousculé la société française et a
changé le paradigme d'un mythe du retour
le sénateur moui on a témoigné on passe
du M du retour à ils vont rester
définitivement dans ce pays et vont
faire partie de la communauté nationale
une fois qu'on l'a dit est-ce que ça se
traduit dans les faits alors ce paradoxe
que vous soullignez dans ces études qui
viennent d'être démontré sur le la
montée à la fois de la tolérance et des
faits de de racisme déctuel c'est un
paradoxe qu'on retrouve sur d'autres
questions plus les Français de cultures
ou de confessions musulmanes se
s'intégre si on doit utiliser le le
faisceau sociologique de l'intégration
plus ils vont poser problème en terme de
représentation parce qu'ils deviennent
visibles quand on parle d'une communauté
qu'on qu'on qu'on invite a rentré dans
son pays avec des politiques d'aide au
retour qui vont exister même sous le la
présidence de François mitteran jusqu'en
8687 on ne se préoccupe pas de cette
communauté là dans l'espace public dans
la communauté nationale une fois qu'elle
fait acte de citoyenneté ce qui est le
cas de ces marcheurs et qu'elle réclame
sa place sur la photo de famille
nationale elle est montrée du doigt
parce qu'elle ose exiger ça part de de
droit de devoir mais aussi de visibilité
qu'on aimerait qu'elle se cantonne à
être une minorité
souriante pas de
problème invisible et amené à quitter le
territoire et pourtant ça a changé
l'image quand même cette marche pour
l'égalitéou seconde génération ça ouvert
la France à la notion
d'interculturalité ça tendu un miroir à
cette France qui ne se voyait que
majoritairement blanche et de culture
gédochchrétienne pour le coup en terme
de culture ça changé on a vu apparître
des artistes oui mais ces artistes là
n'ont pu avoir voix au chapitre tout à
l'heure atlim moli parlait de carte de
séjour avec rachita cher à mon cœur
rachita est avec ses collègues de carte
de séjour la bande son de ses anbur et
il vient se dire artiste français mais
en chantant en arabe donc il revendique
une forme de différence dans
l'indifférence un appel à vivre ensemble
dans le respect des différences de
chacun mais tous ensemble et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui dans la postérité de ce
mouvement citoyen qui est la marche pour
l'égalité contre le racisme il faut
qu'on éte à l'esprit que cette France
multiculturelle elle va avoir enfin ces
lettres de noblesse par la marche pour
l'égalité et elle va aussi permettre
avec un long chemin vers la citoyenneté
à de nombreux hommes et femmes héritiers
de l'immigration de devenir comme ACL
Mouli élu de la
République ministre médecins professeurs
citoyens français heureux et fier de ses
origines mais on est toujours dans dans
une question d'imaginaire ces
imaginaires qui sont pas complètement
décolonisés et qui n'admettent pas que
ces Français sont des Français comme les
autres et bien merci à vous pour ce
débat passionnant à la fois fait
d'histoire et puis de thématiques qui
résonnent encore évidemment aujourd'hui
merci à tous d'y avoir participé je
rappelle votre livre Olivier cour grand
maison he racisme de France aux éditions
La Découverte et puis demain c'est le
général Vincent des portes professeur de
stratégie à sciencep et HC ancien
directeur de l'École de guerre qui sera
à 8h l'invité de la matinale de Public
Sénat on vous retrouve pour sens public
mais avec Thomas HUG dans ce fauteuil
dès
lundi